- I am so excited to meet you.
- It's so lovely to meet you.
- You're so talented.
Not just an actor, a singer,
like every, you're so gifted.
So I thank you for being on the show.
- Thank you so much for
having me! What a treat.
- I'm very, very excited.
So wait, so what I said, the what?
Those were your actual performance?
That, that's actually what they said.
Your reviews.
- That's very kind.
- That's the critics are loving you.
Well, I'm scared of you.
- Okay.
- Because that film is,
I watched it last night
and then I went to bed
and I was like, "Probably
shouldn't have done that."
Yeah.
Like, humans are capable
of just crazy things.
- Absolutely.
- And you're great in everything.
I love you in everything.
- [Eddie] Oh, thank you!
- And I can't wait to
talk about The Good Nurse.
- But-
- Yeah.
- I have to ask because you have kids.
I have kids as well.
Are they, are they more impressed
by Fantastic Beasts than anything else?
You play a wizard.
So...
- You know, my kids are little.
They came to the set of The Good Nurse.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And they knew
that I was, they hung out
with Jessica's children
and we are having a wonderful time,
despite the subject might
have been quite intense.
- That's what I was going to say!
- We actually had a wonderful time making,
and I made the error.
I mean this is horrendous parenting
but of showing them a little bit
of the trailer and, and it transpires.
They had thought that I
was playing The Good Nurse,
and in this film I'm very,
and they were so disappointed.
They're like,
- Very much not, so.
- So, you're the bad nurse.
And I was like, "Yeah."
They definitely prefer me as a wizard.
- Oh my God.
Oh my God.
I know you're one of those,
you're, you're, it's rare
you're one of those actors
that you watch and you're like,
"Are you a little bit of a serial killer?"
Like, 'cause, 'cause you're so good at it.
And then I'm like, "Is he that good?"
I was like, "It was incredible."
My sister and I were watching last night,
and I was just like, "Oh my God!"
She's visiting from out of town
and she was like, "This is crazy good."
And anyway, so what
are your kids into now?
They like Fantastic Beasts, but what else?
- Well, they, they,
I mean I have a boy who
loves a bit of Paw Patrol,
- [Kelly] Oh, I love Paw Patrol, yeah.
- Love a bit of Octonauts, loves,
I mean if the truth be told, he just like,
likes to make anything into a weapon.
- Yeah.
- Which is probably horrendous.
- And I don't know,
I promise I'm quite,
I'm not a serial killer.
I'm a quite gentle person.
But like anything like he'll
turn that into a weapon.
- Yeah.
- Even some flowers or something.
Come in the morning with flowers.
- Yeah.
- I don't know what's going wrong.
How about your little ones?
- Like, my boy's like that.
Yeah.
My girl is kind of like that too.
- Really?
- Yeah.
It's just a crazy house.
Yeah.
They, they, they both like Aquaman.
So they both got tridents
and I was like, "This was a bad idea."
- Yeah.
'Cause things have been broken-
- And you go to the park-
- and they nail each other with them.
- The everything is a sword and-
- Yep.
- And just, we, we just
collected a load of
twigs now that are just
like sticks that-
- He collects sticks?
My son does that too.
- I know.
- Everywhere we go,
I'm like, "No, we cannot
take this one home.
You have like ten!"
- Like a trunk of the
car filled with sticks.
But much better than, than
buying plastic toys, I suppose.
- I guess. I guess.
Yeah, I know, I guess we're the jerks
in that situation.
I hear, does one of your,
is one of your kids musical?
Did I hear?
- Oh well my daughter Iris. My daughter.
So, Broken Voice.
- Yeah, I love that it's
Iris, that's so beautiful.
Oh, that she's just
started playing the piano.
Yeah.
- Oh, that's great.
- And they both love singing,
so they, yeah, it's...
And I love it.
I love, it's just been
these first few days
and she's really enjoying it.
Piano practice is still
a lovely novel thing.
- Yeah.
- Whereas, when I was younger,
I mean when I started playing the piano,
I used to, the days I had
to go to piano lessons,
I would write a note saying
that I'd run away from home.
- Yeah, you like, dreaded it.
- My mom would come in like,
"Ed, it's piano practice."
I'm like, "Did you not get the
notes saying I'd run away?"
She's like, "Yeah, but
you do that every week."
So.
- So do you still play though?
- I do.
That's a beautiful,
that's a beautiful thing.
- Yeah, yeah. Do you play?
- I play poorly.
- [Eddie] Well, so do I.
- Yes.
No, no, no, no.
- Poorly but passionately, Kelly.
- [Kelly] No.
- No?
- No, no.
I am so passionate
about writing in general
and like I love, I think
my problem is I met Jason,
my musical director,
like right after Idol
and like I,
like 20 years ago.
And once you, once you sing with someone
that plays like that.
- Yeah.
- It's daunting.
You're like, "I'm never gonna be able to."
I even tried one tour and
he like worked with me
and I was like "No."
- [Eddie] No.
- It's never gonna be
like how it sounds to you.
And that's not fair to
the people listening."
So, but-
- Also the nerves that
you get playing the piano.
Like I find singing okay. In front people.
- [Kelly] Me too.
- But like the feeling of your,
the wobble of-
- Yes!
- Your hands before playing live.
- And like all of a sudden I'm like,
I don't know any of the notes.
I don't know what I just did.
I don't, I don't remember what I just did.
I just played the whole song.
Yeah. I get very nervous.
- It's so thrilling to hear
that you have the same thing.
- Yeah, but I don't get that with singing.
- It's odd.
- Yeah.
- Really odd.
- So we lost Queen Elizabeth this year,
and not long ago,
I wanna get this right.
She made you an
Officer Of The Most Excellent
Order Of The British Empire.
- That's a lot of words.
- I feel like it's very fancy,
and I just wanna know what it means.
- Very good question.
I'm not sure I can entirely
tell you what it means
but it was, it was an
extraordinary moment.
You get, you get a medal.
- Yeah.
- And you line up in Windsor Castle,
alongside these people who've
done really brilliant things.
Like, you know, sort of people in charge
of the health service
or who've sort of running the
you know, who've sort of curing cancer.
- [Kelly] That kind of thing.
- And you are the person who
like, you know, played the part.
So you feel sort of pretty out of,
but also you get a lesson
in how to genuflect,
in how to kind of what to say
and when to move forward
and when we were being told this,
it just for me, went in one ear
and out the other and,
and I went in to meet
the Queen,
and, everything went out.
And I just sort of mumbled
and kept doing that basically.
But it was a very, very special moment.
- I just love that you
can say that sentence.
"When I walked in to meet the Queen."
- Queen, Oh.
- Like, it's just like
a really cool sentence
to be able to say.
- But we have these odd things in it.
There was another sort
of thing that I got which was called
the Freedom of the City of London.
And it's a very beautiful sort
of certificate you get
and you go to a meet.
I was offered it,
and I was like, "God, how wonderful."
It's very historical.
I can't tell you exactly what it is.
But when I went to the ceremony,
they said, "And what you get,
for this,
is you are now legally allowed
to lead sheep across London Bridge."
And I get to lead sheep
across London Bridge.
And, and-
- This is a really old award.
This has to be a very old award.
- [Eddie] Very old award.
- I mean, I've-
- [Kelly] Do you own sheep?
- I don't own sheep.
- You should get some
just to walk it across
and be like, "I can do this. You can't."
- Can you imagine?
- [Kelly] Yes!
- I mean I have felt like
I want to put that to test.
I think if I really sort
of took some sheep on leads
across London Bridge-
- [Kelly] I really want to see it.
- I might get stopped by the police.
- Who cares? It's, show your certificate!
- Brandishing my certificate.
- Yeah.
- Just hold it.
Have it like hanging,
like the spelling bee people.
- Redmayne's lost it.
- [Kelly] Oh, my god!
- He's like lost the plot.
I just think that's amazing
'cause it's such an old thing.
That probably was a huge deal back then,
that you could actually-
- Take the sheep across.
- Take the sheep.
Well, because that is, for farmers.
That's good.
You get like different
grass over there, whatever.
That's probably a really great thing's.
- Massive deal. Yeah.
- Not so much now.
- Well, I mean.
- Until you try it.
- Until I try it.
- Yeah.
Let's talk about The Good Nurse.
So what I always wonder
when I see these characters
'cause what draws you to do that?
Because it's an insane character.
- Mm. Do you know, I knew
nothing about this story.
- [Kelly] Me neither.
And when I read the script,
the character that
Jessica Chastain plays is this woman,
Amy Loughren is like a,
she's a superhero, really.
- Yeah.
- What she managed to-
- Like a real life one. Yeah.
- A real life superhero.
And so I found it
extraordinarily compelling
and this guy Charlie Cullen,
who I played,
who was very much a bad nurse,
he was also kind of riveting
because I got to speak
to the real Amy Loughren.
And she said there were
just two people in her life.
On the one hand he was
this very gentle, kind,
self deprecating, quite funny man.
And then she met twice this,
this different human being.
And, and so the story was
not only of this hero,
but also how like the systems had failed.
And I found it unlike
anything I'd read. So.
- Did you have to study?
Like to get the terminology like medical?
- Yeah, so, so Jessica Chastain and I
were sent to nurse school.
- Oh, that's cool.
- Which was actually, really intriguing.
But it proved one thing,
which is I'm a like
completely useless nurse.
Never turn to me in a crisis.
It will, it will end in tears.
Jess was very,
Jess was brilliant cause
she was very decisive.
She's a decisive nurse.
She like knows exactly.
You know, she just goes for it.
Whereas, I was quite dithering.
No one wants a dithering nurse.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- But...
- I don't even know anyone
that uses the word dithering.
So you know what? You, congratulations.
- Thank you.
- Like word of the day.
- So I, yeah, but they,
but they would be all these sort
of poor dummies that had been brought in,
and the director would find me on set
in the morning with all these sort
of needles trying to trying to work out
if I could make the thing.
It was, yeah.
It was all a bit of a nightmare.
And there was a real nurse on set.
A lovely man called Joe.
And after each take, not
only would you be looking
for, you know, to see with the director
whether you'd done it okay.
- You'd look down to see-
- More terrifyingly, it was
like, "Joe did I? Did it?"
And you know
But he was brilliant and
specific, which is cool.
- Yeah. And honest?
- Very honest. Not missing his voice.
- I gathered that from your tone.
- Y'all have got to see
this movie, it's so good.
The Good Nurse is in theaters now!
And on Netflix October 26th!